cinematic getaways dreaming about your
own forest moon getaway in the Outer Rim
welcome to the Imperial in Indore our
luxurious all-inclusive treetop retreat
lets you indulge in the end or
experience feel the local flavour upon
arrival with a warm welcome from the
natives lay back and relax as you're
whisked away to the resort let the
vacation begin with a nap on one of our
nature inspired moss beds dine at our
five-star restaurant our expert chefs
have a decadent menu that's to die for
recreation of bounds in this tropical
paradise hike meandering trails full of
magical surprises take a relaxing cruise
above the forest floor on a hover bike
built for two or get physical with our
II walk Adventure Club with fun
activities like hang gliding archery or
a friendly game of capture the death
star shield generator when it comes to
nightlife Endor knows how to party the
hottest live music captivating campfire
tales and plenty of secluded spots for
whispering sweet nothings to that
special someone relax
explore enjoy the Imperial Inn Endor